[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants bougent trop gros
mais et bonsoir chers nounours je te
trouve une voix mes amis nicolas et
pimprenelle bien sûr nounours mais ne
soit pas trop long je t'attends ou le
sol a tout de suite nounours hop hop hop
hop hop hop on au port aux eaux et alors
qu'un prenez-le souhaite une bonne
blague
il va être bien trapu nounours bon alors
tu as bien compris
ouais je me mets au lit et jeudi
courcoux ce mois nounours je peux entrer
30 ans bonsoir mes petits hommes ne fait
pas trop de bruit que ce poste et au
patronat le très malade
le cocher bouffe petit peu preneur je
vais la fois
alors petite fille
on a bon goût non faut pas lui parler
elle se repose elle n'a pas une maladie
contagieuse
oh non non tu sais bien que je t'aurais
pas laisser un trait si c'était une
maladie comme comme tu dis bref petit
c'est fred lens est ce que moi je t'aime
beaucoup ou là que se passe-t-il
ce n'est pas pas preneur elle tord j'ai
dû rêver quand irène menace mais ça fait
peur sur matters snepap cola nounoune
ans
moi je t'aime ou y encore bang c'est
trop fort qu'est ce qui m'a fait bon sur
la tête à moi tu sais moi luttent m
oui houle ma pauvre petit parce que je
donne à mon coeur bat les quotas il
était d'accord et pas prêtes elles
n'avaient pas mal à la tête ils m'ont
fait mais c'est vrai
l'ornement petites jambes
bon si je vous jure ou de dos et au
visage
post 10 ans damien draper howie alors
mais maintenant dormait vite
oui c'est bien beau de nuit chagrin le
nonce à demain bonne nuit les enfants
beaux mots mais tu as l'air bien content
nous nous battrons mes deux petits amis
m'ont fait une bonne blague
bam bam et puis se sont couchés sagement
alors je suis content et je sens aux
mots aux miens en route fidèle compagnon
en route seul patron ban et nuit aux
deux
[Musique]